foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman show
you guessed it America it's Ken Coleman
himself and we are excited to take your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you want to talk
about getting out of debt getting on a
budget Building Wealth paying off the
house switching jobs getting a side
hustle we can talk about all that stuff
can you yeah absolutely you know Dave
has said for decades that your income is
your greatest wealth building tool and
I'm the personality that specializes in
making more money but also experiencing
more meaning so increase the income
increase your impact it is possible now
more than ever
you're good at that yeah well you know
I'm a preacher's kid so I speak in
alliteration I can't help myself it's
memorable it is so there you go let's do
it let's do it J's kicking us off in San
Diego AJ welcome to the show
hey George hey Ken thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
so um I've got a career question
um I I want to know how to plan for the
future here I'm very very fortunate uh
financially but my concern is around the
culture in my in my company I work for a
small investment brokerage not many
people run heavily from the top down and
if it was just a on a financial basis I
would stay here forever I like what I do
I like building relationships and sales
but like I say it's just kind of the
culture that you know has me concerned
from a principal standpoint what
specifically or what are you comfortable
sharing as it relates to this culture
stuff that's wanting you to driving you
crazy making you want to leave
uh it's coming from the top down and so
in this in this role it's uh you know
commission-based job with preset you
know
um percentages or commissions if you
will and
um I think because for a small group and
and just the dynamic of it my managing
broker uh will you know dip his hand
into the pot and okay I want you to be
more specific so AJ you're saying you
don't agree with the com structure and
you feel like your boss is stealing from
you
yeah the com structure is very clear but
the comp structure is not followed
um I can give you an example that's what
I'm looking for you give me an example
perfect so this will happen one every
four or five deals
um where uh so we did a deal just
recently to close that
um
you know the total Commission on the
deal was 70 000 uh give or take my comp
on the deal
um based on our contract is 35
000 I end up with 20.
so you're supposed to get 50 of any
Commission
right yeah well what was the reason
given was there any reason given for why
you took a fifteen thousand dollar hit
on a on a commission that is laid out
clearly in your employment agreement
yeah the reason is the same as it always
is I'm I'm good to you I give you
opportunity and
um you know so I'm I'm just not changing
it okay so what's your question because
I'm ready to rip this leader of yours as
this This Disaster this this bad boss
this this is this is manipulation it's
it's horrible oh I couldn't hold it in
George what was your question yeah I
know what it is from a psychological
standpoint
um the reason I'm still holding on is
because at the end of the day
I I still do really well here and you
know I wonder am I gonna I feel like I'm
winning a lottery ticket as far as
income and am I going to get that
somewhere else okay so what do you sell
real estate okay bro
um first of all if you're good at
selling real estate you can sell real
estate for anybody anywhere anytime but
this is eating away at you
and it should for sure I know and listen
it's not going to get better
I'm gonna call you out on something
because I'm your friend
I think you're scared I think you're
scared to leave because I think you'll
you don't believe you can do what you're
doing anywhere else I think that's
pretty apparent and so I think you got
some fear maybe some doubt and I think
that's what's keeping you there but let
me tell you something you either
overcome this fear and doubt and leave
or
you're going to become so resentful so
bitter and something bad is gonna happen
as opposed to you taking control of your
life and not be treated this way
that's a great point I know
so AJ I only see two options here either
you leave or you deal with it and go hey
I'm going to set up a meeting with
another leader bring them into it and
say Here's what's going on I need a
solution for this
can you do that is there another leader
that you can involve
D no no it's such a small team there's
there's six of us and I'm you know so is
that person basically the CEO are they
running the company
yeah yeah it's manipulation it's over
the today was the day we decided now
we're gonna go find another broker or
another firm or whatever and you're
going to relationship yourself into this
okay your head's going to be high
shoulders back and you're going to be
bold because you know you can sell so go
right go where you're treated properly
you have not hit the lottery at all in
fact the next job where you actually get
paid your full commission that might
feel like you hit the lottery but right
now you're you're being manipulated
true I mean that you know the one caveat
being is no Carolina business comes in
and he he does you know hand it out
right does it matter it doesn't matter
you feel like a victim right now you're
like a dog that's been hit its whole
life
and every time every time he hits you
every time you hit that dog it's like
the dog going well he does feed me
consistently
brings a lot of food home who cares man
every time that he takes from your
commission that is rightfully yours
based on the agreement that he made or
she made with you it is absolutely
manipulating you and it is destructive
and you have bought the narrative you've
bought the lie because you don't think
you can go to us this listen this is
done
there's nothing there's no more caveats
and so from a career perspective
um I don't you know I almost feel like I
I like the business I want to I want to
go off someday and do it myself I want
to be you know the managing broker of my
own business so do I do I stick out
until I feel ready to do that I feel
like later no you'll never be ready my
man no you just gotta start
would you would you tell someone to stay
in a place where they're just being
abused
no no don't stay stay in the business
but go work for somebody else and then
when we make this next move here's what
I want you focusing on what do I need to
learn that I don't know now that will
set me up and put me in a place where I
could work for myself and we're gonna go
get that experience go get that
knowledge do you understand
yeah that's awesome that's what I've
been thinking about do it stop thinking
thanks guys all right you got it man man
that lack of Integrity we're not moving
past that it's time it's not gonna
change this guy is who he says he is 100
and bold about it hey I bring it to you
I take care of you I'm gonna not give
you your full commission this time yeah
by the way Kiss the Ring what are we
doing no thanks Tom Hanks that's what I
gotta say to that Ken hey it's a spicy
Friday give us a call Triple eight eight
two five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Ken
Coleman we are taking your calls about
life money career The Pursuit of
Happiness impact and income it's all
here on the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five Patty
joins us up next in Austin Texas Patty
welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
what's going on
so
um so we have a decision to make as a
family uh we are currently staying in
Austin we bought a home uh we closed the
home last year in uh November so we have
been staying in this house for since
March of this year uh my wife got a new
job offer in California and we were
wondering if moving to California does
it make sense based on the salary height
that she is getting and if yes then what
do we need to do with this house we
don't want to sell it so does renting
this house makes sense
Okay so
excitement level on a scale of one to
ten one being no excitement ten being
throwing a party how excited is your
wife and then how excited are you about
the potential of moving to California
for this job
I think my wife is pretty excited not
because it's California just because of
the role so that she's getting [ __ ] like
the company and everything and I think
it's it's going to be a good good
project for us going forward so okay
she's pretty excited and I'm also a very
supportive of her because I can in my
job I can work from anywhere yeah so
just financially does it make sense
that's the question well so on the
financial piece break it down for George
and I so uh what's the what's the cost
of living increase uh from her
standpoint is she getting a nice bump in
salary
right so I'll walk you through our
current situation and then the situation
in California so all all in Gross uh
income so right now I make 140 uh 140
000 she makes 125 000 days plus each of
us uh in total would make uh are making
close to 29 000 in bonuses
um each year so total income you can say
294 000 right now in Texas
um when we moved to California I'm
assuming my salary is going to stay same
that's the worsted scenario right so
I'll be making same 140 uh base but she
is getting 195 000. okay uh in
California plus uh bonus structure will
remain same but because uh her base is
increasing so the bonus would be around
33 500. right so total would be 368
000 uh dollars plus she's also getting
stocks and yearly that's uh the stock
listing is close to 100 000 so we're
talking about a 70k bump in income and
so then it comes down to the math of we
know the taxes are going to be higher
the cost of living is going to be higher
in California does that equate to under
seventy thousand towards still a net win
yeah guys
uh so even when I put so in this
assumption I'm thinking that our current
home would go on rent
so even in that terms if I make that
assumption I would we would be saving
close to ten thousand four hundred
dollars more compared to what we do here
yearly okay in California how much do
you owe on the home in Austin
uh close to 340. what's it what's it
worth if you sold it today
I checked everything it says 525
okay and then what price point have you
done your homework on homes and what
they cost in the area where you guys are
going to be living
I don't think I'm going to buy property
in California so soon uh so we would be
renting at least for next couple of
years in California for sure yeah if I'm
in your shoes I'm selling your property
in Austin I'm with you for a few reasons
number one being a long-distance
landlord is a recipe for disaster yeah
and number two you guys aren't in a
financial position obviously the income
is great
but you're going to be paying rent on
top of hoping that you have a
responsible tenant who pays on time that
can pay the mortgage right that's always
I put that in air quotes you can't see
unless you're watching but that's the
part that worries me and so I would get
I know it's it's there may be a stupid
tax involved here because you guys just
moved in recently and so after realtor
fees and it may not have appreciated
that much uh you're gonna have to pay
capital gains on the profits
as well because you've only been there
for a few months correct
yeah so I mean she's still after joining
the job so she still has six months to
eight months to move to California so I
think we can stay one year in this
property and make it a long-term capital
gain instead of Customs that's better at
least yeah so I'm still selling it I
think you guys will leave with uh what
116 change in equity
right that can help kick-start your
journey in California and if you're in
California long term you're going to
want to buy something even though it's
insane and that might mean you save up
six hundred thousand dollars with your
amazing income and buy a nine hundred
thousand dollar property years from now
okay and another thing that I was
thinking what if we pay off this
property the does it make sense to hold
on this property and rent it out or
still paying off doesn't make sense and
still you're still long distance
landlord the question is when you're in
California would you go buy a house in
Austin to rent out
right yeah the answer is probably no
no and so I think the time to be a real
estate investor is once we can pay cash
for another property and our current
home is paid off and you guys can do I
mean with this income it won't take long
for you guys to do that if you keep
living on less than you may can be
you're clearly very intentional you're a
super smart guy and so I think you can
get there but right now that wouldn't be
my go-to I have a follow-up question
Patty is this a a hybrid model well even
if you were to move to California will
she be required to be in the office
every day do you know that because I
know she's working remote for a season
in Austin
yeah she has to be in office it's a
manufacturing company
and you've looked at rent in that area
that's close by to her work
yeah it's the worst come worse it would
be like if we go for a single family
home it would be around four thousand
four thousand two hundred dollars okay
but we can move into apartment I mean we
have been staying in apartment from past
20 yeah 15 years as long as that rent is
about 25 of your take-home pay that
leaves you with plenty of margin to live
the rest of your life invest 15 of your
income into retirement pay off the house
early do you guys have kids
no no Casey okay did she get recruited
on this or did she go seek this position
um
she so she yeah she has a pretty good
experience in launching on electric
vehicles she used to work for Tesla
before okay let me ask you this this is
this is a very quick point but I gotta
know if if a company in Texas had
had called
and offered the same position
um and and so you have now one in in
Texas and one in California which one
which which is let's say was the same
thing which one would you all take
of Texas yeah I got to tell you
um
when someone recruits you it feels
really good it does it feels good to be
wanted
um right but I I just wonder if long
term financially if you guys if if she
doesn't go all right what if I look for
something in a different state that's
not as expensive what if I look for
something in the Texas area and I can
further my career in Texas you don't
have to take every good offer because
I'm just I just want to throw it out
there I'm not in any way trying to talk
you out of going to California at all
I'm not anti-california but I'm being
very realistic on the financial
implications of moving to California to
to to do something that she can do in
another state so if it were me I I would
be sitting down going okay if we want to
move up can we move up in other places
do we have to take this opportunity
which is a good opportunity I don't know
that this is a great opportunity you you
may think it is and if you think it is
then do it but I at least wanted to put
that out there are they paying any
relocation costs
and check out the area figure out what
the different neighborhoods are where
you want to rent and that'll make you
feel a little more peace about the move
in case you do it yeah I think to Ken's
point it doesn't have to happen and so
think about the future and what you guys
want to do long term as well I just have
so many friends that are moving here uh
in our state where we have no state
income tax and the amount of money they
are making by simply moving out of a
high-tech State it's it's realistic
sometimes or to your point George how
much money and how long it takes to save
up a money to just buy how save up money
to buy a house in a state like that
where real estate is so high it's you
got to think about the big picture well
they have a great shovel at least and
that helps with this whole situation
absolutely way to go this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
I feel like right now is the time of
year when it's make or break when it
comes to our goals we had a reset when
school started again and now we're
heading into a holiday season and let's
be real it's hard to stay motivated one
says spending frenzy starts we've all
got goals whether it's to find a better
job make more money pay off some debt
build stronger relationships and it can
be hard to keep that momentum going but
here's the good news coming up in a
couple weeks we have one of our biggest
events smart conference we're coming to
Dallas Texas for a day-long jam-packed
event where you'll get advice from
leading experts on money personal growth
career mental health and your marriage
you're going to leave with all the
knowledge and motivation you need to
reach your goals and live the life that
you want so join me and the rest of the
gang all the Ramsey personalities will
be they'll be there Dave Ramsey Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman Christina Ellis
Rachel Cruise it's going to be a good
time it's a special event and by the way
it's more than just speaking we've got
some fun things planned very
entertaining almost too much
entertainment yeah you and Rachel are
doing a little uh is it like a version
of your new podcast we're doing a live
interactive uh podcast does that mean
that you'll have the beverages the adult
beverage honestly it might be a mocktail
we don't know yet you know it's early in
the day Ken we can't go I have a
recommendation for you or Rachel what's
that
um my wife recently had a had a nice
beverage with some Elderberry in it oh
yes like a vodka base for the immune
system yeah a little Elderberry dropped
right in there and boy she thought it
was really refreshing I know you're not
taking suggestions but I thought I'd
give you a suggestion it's a good
wintertime drink Ken thank you for that
so uh October 22nd we're all going to be
there it's a day-long and it's like
drinking from the fire hose Ken I mean
it is you're gonna leave exhausted but
also so motivated it's a lot of energy
whenever you put 6 000 people in a room
that are there for at least a common
goal of getting better uh there's just a
lot of juice in the room you know and
it's a great event to bring friends
family who may not you know they may not
be in with the Ramsay gang yeah and they
can get a taste of what we're all about
we've got a theme going here
the Elderberry juice I mean this is uh
gosh Ken you're too good I know it's
happening so go to ramseysolutions.com
events and get your tickets today join
us uh you don't have much time and it's
going to be a great time I guarantee
that we'd love to see you there Dallas
we're coming near you soon coming to you
soon not near you actually coming to you
we'll be in the Heart of Dallas yeah
there you go all right yeah back to the
phones we go triple eight eight two five
five two two five Ethan joins us up next
in Madison Wisconsin Ethan welcome to
the show
hi thanks how's it going doing great how
are you what's going on
good uh so I graduated in May of 2021
last year and uh over that course of
time I paid off twenty thousand dollars
in student loans I just took the first
job I could get out of school and
hustled and grinded and did that and
then I'd come to find out a student loan
forgiveness thing is happening
and I found that I'm eligible to apply
to like get my money back so to speak
I'd have to go back into debt with my
loan provider and then have my dad
forgiven that way
um how should I go about that should I
do that go back into debt in order to be
forgiven uh is that wise okay all right
I gotta jump in George sure quick uh
because I read entirely too much news
every day there are now multiple
lawsuits that have been filed by
multiple States
against President Biden's executive
action this is not it's not me making
this up this is happening the reason is
is because you have a lot of privately
held student loans and so when he made
that executive action to say we're going
to pay off we're going to forgive ten
thousand it's affecting and again I'm
not I'm not defending it I'm just saying
it's real money that's that's that's
hurting private companies that hold
loans and people sign up for and then
the states are motivated to protect
those companies because those companies
are tax paying companies in their state
so I don't know if you're paying
attention to the news Ethan but that has
happened and so you have two things
going on so the lawsuits have been filed
so the ten thousand dollar forgiveness
is not happening until those lawsuits
are all dealt with number one number two
there there's they're they're not
actively moving towards those refunds
right now anyway so I I just want to put
that out there George because people
feel like this is a done deal I'm going
to go ahead and move forward with this
and it's the basis of his question so I
don't think it's going to happen yeah
and for those listening that aren't
clear on how this is working because
Ethan's going well they're going to put
me back into debt but it's forgiveness
so what we've been seeing is the student
loan companies are saying all right
we're going to drop 10 grand back into
your bank account but we are also
reinstating your debt balance to ten
thousand dollars and now the hope is
down the line at some point the
government comes and wipes that ten
thousand balance makes my head hurt only
the government can come up with
something that's stupid it's pretty
convoluted but that's how it's working
right Ethan am I right on that
uh yeah that's what you described sounds
right to me so no no don't do it so
here's what here's what some people are
doing I'm not going to advocate for
against this but what they're doing is
saying hey I'm gonna take that ten
thousand dollars in the bank and make
sure not to spend it which that takes a
level of discipline alone for people who
had already gone into debt uh thinking
that this was a good idea and then
they're saying I'm going to hang on to
the 10 000 in case they don't forgive it
and I'll still have the money to pay it
off Ken oh sure that sounds wonderful so
Ethan that's kind of what you're
describing as a if you go through with
this that's what the hope is is that you
hang on to the 10 000 and once it's
forgiven you go all right cool this
money is free and clear now
gotcha gotcha so there's risk involved
is what we're saying and unnecessary
risk so don't do it
pay your student loans off the
government is not going to do it for you
and you're completely debt free now
yeah what baby step are you on now
um I was in four five and six but I just
replaced the transmission my car sent
back on three restocking that emergency
fund good man nice well you know what's
clear to me is that the secret sauce to
winning with money is Ethan and not a
third party not a government not a
forgiveness program and so I'm sticking
with the Ethan program for now and if
you so choose to do it I'm not mad at
you I'm happy for you for it to you know
Propel your financial Journey but
there's a lot of risk and a lot of
unknowns right now yeah certainly just
wait wait until the dust settles in the
form of all these lawsuits yeah I
appreciate the call
where's my little where's my little
thing we're just riling up Ken again
he's getting heartburn I want to hear
about the government and this this thing
it gets me right here we got the
tropical thumbs out back we'll get them
before you can on the break all right
blinds.com question of the day coming up
here they're 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you miss measure or you
pick the wrong color they will remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code Ramsay to
get the best deal today's question comes
from Brittany in Illinois I work full
time at a large church and I love she
put in all caps my job but make forty
five thousand dollars a year I'm a
single mom homeowner and drive a modest
car even though I don't live
extravagantly I'm still living paycheck
to paycheck almost all my income is
going to tithe my mortgage bills and
income property taxes I used to make
fifty to a hundred dollars an hour as a
digital marketing copywriter but stopped
doing that when offered my current job
in Ministry with income is our biggest
wealth building tool but also living a
christ-centered life would you recommend
someone quitting the job in Ministry to
pursue a higher paying job my biggest
motivation to becoming financially free
is so that I can continue working in
Ministry without the stress of making
ends meet do I find a higher paying job
for a few years to get to baby step four
and then come back to Ministry uh that's
probably the direction but I want to go
back to some things that you know
you can desire to be in Ministry
but if you cannot in the ministry is
just like any other job
in that there's a pay range a scale
right for the type of job you do in
Ministry just like in industry
and even though you desire to work in
Ministry if you cannot if you're not
qualified and you aren't able to make
the amount of money that you need to
make
then what we need to do is go okay what
does Ministry look like
in another form in in other words you
can volunteer
you can work part-time in Ministry but
we've got to be able to sustain
ourselves and accomplish the financial
goals and I think if you can make 50 to
100 hours a digital marketing copywriter
but you stopped I'd get back into that
field to get the highest paying day job
possible now for the whole purpose of
getting the baby step four right and
getting your financial life stable to
where you can then go all right I could
take a bit of a pay cut but why not
maybe go back to full-time day job do
some volunteer or part-time Ministry
work it's still valuable it is still
feeding that passion you have to
minister to others but it doesn't have
to be a full-time job that's okay too
yeah if you love your job but your
finances are so tight that you're so
stressed then you're not gonna have a
great life and there's more to it than
that so I want you to go back to that
marketing role maybe it's in a
Consulting part-time position but it
sounds like man you can Propel your
Finance journey by jumping back into
that full time right now so it's a good
call Ken thanks for the question this is
the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast join this hour
by the host of the Ken Coleman Show Ken
Coleman you can find all of those shows
on the Ramsey Network or wherever you
listen to podcasts it's a free call this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life your money and your
career David joins us up next in
Virginia David welcome to the show
thank you how's it going
good man how about you good good how can
we help today
yeah mine's more of a just a choice
question because I'm not sure but I'm
going to build background uh my wife and
I are both come around 60. uh health is
so so that's one of our concerns is
always health care of course
um we own a small business franchise at
this point in our lives we're debating
whether to
sell the franchise and go into another
franchise it maybe Isn't So labor
intensive or just go back to corporate
or we can get some decent health care
and ride it out that way so we can just
take care of ourselves tell us a little
bit about the business itself what kind
of what kind of business is it and what
kind of money is it throwing off
uh commercial cleaning
um been doing 15 years
um revenues are about 1-7
um so it's stable what are you paying
yourself off the one seven
um I'm thinking 60 miles taking 40.
wow where is the rest going
um most of it's being tucked away
because we're debt free
um we have a house to pay for so that's
grown and gone no College they are tests
so you don't have a lot of overall no is
it just the two of you just the two of
you doing the cleaning uh no no we have
a staff of about 30. oh okay well that's
where a lot of that revenue is going too
is payroll so when you say labor
intensive you don't mean manual labor on
your end you're just saying the headache
that it brings yeah my my I couldn't do
it if I want to do it my age but um how
much have you got saved for retirement
currently in our portfolio about 1.2
and what could you get for the business
if you sold it
uh we're getting evaluated right now but
we're guessing six
600 000 probably six hundred thousand
six hundred thousand on 1.7 in gross
revenue
that doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense to me I've never heard it that way
but I do mean 1.7 million in gross
revenue per year correct correct a
million of that goes to payroll
hmm that just seems awfully low I
thought you were saying 6 million which
sounded a lot closer
where'd you come up with that number
based on other franchises that are
similar that have been sold ah okay well
I got to tell you I'd sell it I'd get
out of that business there's just really
no long-term benefit for it the fact
that you're in your 60s you got health
issues uh the good news is you've got
great you know pretty good retirement
set up and you can continue to do so but
yeah I would cash out but I would not at
this age go into another franchise
that's just me
um I'm gonna go low risk no risk is what
we're saying I'm gonna go no risk
and uh you guys have a lot to offer I
feel like your heart has left this
business and so I think it's time for
your body to do the same so I would cash
out and that will set you guys up nicely
with your nest egg and if you want to go
corporate to get some health care that's
not a bad idea but I don't want you to
do it just for the health care you do do
you guys have long-term care in place
we don't right now now and and for me
it's more of you know I still want to
work of course I still want to bring
some income in because we're not ready
to fully retire yet right but at the
same time I
I want to punch a clock and call it a
day and spend time with my wife and go
visit my daughter then do that that's
honorable
do it because we were you know the
decisions between being self-employed as
we are and continuing that route and
having all those headaches that come
with it or just working with something
has been something my wife and I have
toyed with a lot yeah I just feel like
we're hearing a guy who doesn't want any
more headaches he just want to work for
somebody go do good do a good job and
leave work at work and go live your life
you just said as much
yeah I think you're right
well I mean you're the one that's saying
it it's not in my opinion this is what I
heard and I I think in some way you're
you're calling us uh for permission and
I'm trying to Grant you permission to do
what it is we hear you say that you want
to do
it's just so hard to look at it and say
you know you've been working for
yourself basically and there's a lot of
perks that come with that
um as opposed to you know reporting to
someone that's right so I want to make
sure we're set up to be able to retire
uh one day and you know just actually do
that at a decent age well I think you
are
George when you agree you're the money I
think he's set up now you're only going
to add to it if you sell the company but
let me let me just put it to you this
way working for yourself in this current
company do the perks outweigh the
headaches yes or no
financially that's the only side of it
right yeah so I'm going to ask it again
you just gave me a caveat do the perks
all of them do the perks outweigh the
headaches no no you tried to be a
politician on me on a Sunday Morning
Show the difference between me and those
Sunday morning host is I'm gonna hold
you down it's not fooling around not
messing around
midterms are coming up you know
David listen you've done a good job man
I I I think what you want to do is the
right thing to do don't you George yeah
I think you to give you guys some peace
and Clarity I would connect with the
smartvestor pro yes and run the numbers
because right now you're kind of hoping
and wishing not really sure what the
number is that you guys could actually
retire with
and I'm over here crunching some numbers
for you if you took that 600 Grand and
you just plopped it in an a taxable
brokerage account within seven six seven
years that'll be over a million on top
of your 1.2 and so you guys have to look
at your lifestyle and how much income
would we need to withdraw from our nest
egg every year to have a great
retirement do all the things you're
talking about David and that'll give you
some great clarity but you're in a great
spot how do you feel about what George
just threw at you
um and it definitely puts a spark in it
you know without a doubt there we go
George you in that calculator I love a
good calculator you just inspired David
you just inspired sometimes it just
takes a little math that's all it is but
once you have that David you guys are
you've worked so hard and you've lived
unless and you make you're debt free
you've been doing this stuff and you got
to remember what the reason is yeah it's
not just to punch the clock
and David the numbers that George gave
you that doesn't even count you working
five or six more years that's if you
just put 600 Grand in and never touched
it and just put it in some good funds
and you never clean another corporate
office the rest of your life I wanted to
throw that in there how does that feel
Dave that works for me uh see we got
saved in a good mood Ken boy we did he's
chuckling I love it I like a good Chuck
I'm here for it yeah all right let's
take another one Megan joins us in
Kansas City Megan welcome to the show
hi thank you
um my question is my husband and I are
on on baby steps four or five six and my
question is outside of the 529 where
could we save for our children's future
do you feel like it's not enough in the
529
college and my family is a combination
of kids who
get their PHD law degree as well as kids
who cannot learn the traditional way
maybe an Associates at best but go more
the trade school certificates
um continuing
seminars that type of stuff and I kind
of just want
both my kids to be set up kind of
equally when they turn 18
bulk of it they're under two oh two kids
under two I thought you were gonna say
they're like 16. okay we got plenty of
time here you're just worried hey what
if they don't need the funds for
education
yeah what if they don't need the phone
certification but I do want to make sure
and I say aye my husband and I do want
to make sure that they are you know set
up to succeed but even if they don't go
to college they'll they'll they will
pursue some sort of Education right
yeah even if it's in the trades
uh yeah that's that's the goal and so
that money can be used towards any
expense when it comes to education it
doesn't have to be a four-year
University it can be towards housing and
laptops and all the things required to
do that and you can always change the
beneficiary
so if one kid needs more the other one
doesn't you can change the names and
move that money around
okay
so you're still just saying sick with
the 529
even if you want to make sure that they
are set up and they just go straight
into work yes because if they go
straight into work they don't need a
hundred thousand dollars sitting there
because they're going to have earned
income with no expense at that point
so there's not really anything this to
save for I mean they you can do
custodial IRAs and what's called an utma
uniform transfer to minors act there's
all kinds of things like that but I
wouldn't worry about that at this point
okay yeah you're doing great though at
two years old you're already thinking
about this most parents it's just oh my
gosh they're 18. I guess we need to oh
we're broke take out student loans we'll
co-sign and so the fact you're thinking
about this tells me they're gonna be
okay and the future of education is
probably only getting more expensive Kim
so I'd rather at least plan for
something and decide later thanks for
the call that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books my thanks to
all the folks in the booth Jenna Ben
James Zach Andrew holgang and you Ken
Coleman thank you appreciate it we'll be
back with you before you know it
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined by my colleague Mr Ken
Coleman this hour and we are here for
you to take your calls to give you that
next step to maybe help you have a
breakthrough and something you're going
through whether that's with your money
or your career so call us at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Griffin is kicking us off in Charleston
South Carolina Griffin welcome to the
show
hey guys thanks so much for having me my
dad and I are a huge fans so really
appreciate your time thank you
I want some guidance here on what to
tackle in terms of my loans or just to
keep stacking money in my savings
account
um currently have three main loans
between my town home student loans as
well as my car
um and to break down the numbers for you
the town home was just recently
purchased 410
000 put down 10 and the current loans
for 368 535 that's not a seven year arm
at 4.75 I just paid my first mortgage on
the first of October and that was 2 365
which I own the property myself however
if you split that payment with my
girlfriend that lives with me
okay and then we've got my student you
haven't got my student loans
um those to be perfectly honest with you
I have not paid in a while
um but there's about six different loans
between three point seven six percent
and four point six percent and the
standing balance on that is 26 654 and
then there's the car which is a three
point six ten percent loan
um and that total is nine thousand four
hundred and fifty five dollars and I'm
paying that every month obviously which
is a 341 payment okay what's your
question
my question is I've got income of about
175 000 a year 26 and I've been
fortunate enough to be put into this
position
um do I continue to do the minimum
payments on these loans or should I pay
my car off all in one month which
basically I'm a last commission check
that I just earned I can do that
um plus save some
um I'm trying to to try to get some
guidance here on what next steps to take
to get to the point of financials
Freedom really as quick as possible I
love it well one way to get to Financial
Freedom as quickly as possible is to
stop going into debt so are we on the
same page that there is no more debt in
the picture
no more dead in the pastry I don't have
a credit card okay great so but all the
other things are debt
the car loan the student loan the town
home so here's one thing you mentioned a
lot of interest rates which tells me you
love math
you love to the numbers and justifying
every purchase right
yes sir so one thing we're going to do
it's really hard for people like you who
are sharp is to ignore the interest
rates
okay now if we ignore the interest rates
and we start listing these balances from
smallest to largest that tells me that
car loan is gone this month then we're
attacking the student loans those are
going to be gone in a few more months
right and then we're going to build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then the house that'll come
later we're not going to worry about
that as part of our Consumer Debt
I should have mentioned I have 56 000 in
savings well that helps
we're debt free today my man what are
you waiting for
I should imagine that 10 000 in my
chapter so why are you hanging on to the
56 and not just paying off the debt as
it's accruing interest
because the well that's a great question
I think uh a large part of it is because
I want to stay for a town home I didn't
know how much exactly I needed until I
made the purchase which was just done in
the last three or four months so that
money is really residual from the money
I was saving up for a down payment so
you decided I'm just going to put 10
down and leave the rest in the bank
the difference between the 10 to 15 and
the offer that was provided it was
really not it wasn't it didn't make
enough sense for me to do the additional
five percent so I just put 10 down
that's correct and so this is you know
what like I just said just did my first
mortgage payment so kind of in one month
one of uh owning this property and
living it okay and trying to decide what
to do with my money yeah he's spinning
plates George she's got There's an
actual plates there's 17 things at once
number one it does worry me that the
girlfriend is paying into this and she
doesn't own any part of it and if this
doesn't work out she's gonna feel like
she got screwed right
um there you know I can't speak for
anybody here um but I what I do know is
that that did come to the situation by
salary alone would would pay and then my
commission on top right would would be
okay I would be able to pay these other
bills right so that that is I am in that
position I'll tell you what I would do
what Dave Ramsey would do if he was
sitting here and that is to be
completely debt free by the end of the
day and use the rest of the money as an
emergency fund and we're gonna then
start investing 15 of our income into
retirement any money beyond that is
going to get thrown at the mortgage and
I would probably look at refinancing
when it makes sense over to a 15-year
fixed rate because those adjustable rate
mortgages are the worst
okay very dangerous I appreciate it
so you're in a great spot we just have
to start doing things with Focus
intensity one at a time but the good
news is you can do this all tomorrow if
you decide to
okay so you know in terms of that's
exactly what I wanted to hear was I feel
like I'm putting a lot of attention
towards a few different things rather
than focusing and owning it as you know
a gazelle intensity as they would say
towards one of these exactly I mean you
know this stuff I'm just curious how
come you haven't done it it seems like
you've been listening for a while
um I I think a lot of it is uh I am
financially conservative and I like
being the bank account grow there's that
level of uh Pride but then the other the
other half of it is I I am 26 and I I am
taking uh these steps a little quicker
than than maybe some people would but
you know there's no excuse for that I'm
I'm ready to tackle this and start
making folks tomorrow so well your
greatest wealth billing tool is your
income you make an amazing income at 26
of 175 000 and I just want to see it
work for you instead of it disappear
into the abyss and you're going I don't
feel like I'm making great progress uh I
I'm listening in here I'm listening
intently Coach Ken jump in I'm going to
uh I I think you have been tinkering
because you like finances
um I think you like strategies and
that's going to make you uh susceptible
and into Temptations to Tinker and so
here's my Coach Ken my Coach Ken phrase
stop tinkering
and start focusing focus on the baby
steps the way George laid them out
you've been listening to show just focus
on the baby steps stop tinkering around
you know what I mean just start you're
going to get further you're going to get
further with Focus right and uh and now
you you know you can always be curious
and see what options are for you long
term but that's after you get yourself
in a financially stable situation you
got it
yes sir absolutely
have you read The Total Money Makeover
Griffin
I haven't but I'm going to well can I
send it to you or do you already have a
copy
I don't have a copy but now you do boom
we're gonna ship it to you my man hang
on the line Austin will pick up and we
will send you a copy of The Total Money
Makeover that book gets me pumped every
time I still read it once a year just to
stay focused and stay motivated the
audiobook is great too so hang on the
line we'll get that to you but right now
focus is the operative word here and you
make a great income at a young age and
if you can use it and channel it like a
laser dude you can do some amazing
things with your money stop tinkering
start focusing I was hoping for a pretty
smart chalkboard I was really hoping on
a chalkboard right there
all right I'll take it Ken all right
pretty good tweet that this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
foreign
[Music]
folks here's a friendly reminder that
you can visit us here at the Ramsey
Solutions headquarters just south of
Nashville Tennessee we were just out
there meeting some nice folks taking
some pictures signing some books having
a good time so come visit us make it a
point on your uh your trips as you're
traveling around the country to come see
us we've got a free baked goods and free
coffee and you get a free mug and we've
got a fun timeline wall Museum and a
full bookstore and it is a good time
it's fantastic Nashville is a great City
to visit to begin with yeah yeah it's
you know years ago when I was hosting
the just the video channel
um had some folks come by and they asked
me to sign their baby
that's a true story uh so don't please
please don't bring your babies and ask
us to sign them like Sharpie on skin
Sharpie on the little guy's leg
I feel uncomfortable I didn't do it okay
oh good you didn't go through with it
yeah I just said they asked me to sign
well I redirected
don't make it weird people that's all we
gotta say there you go all right let's
go to the phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call Grant joins us in Spokane
Washington Grant welcome to the show
thank you very much gentlemen I just
want to say thanks for accomplishing
your mission on a daily basis oh thank
you oh that's very nice thank you sir
what's going on all right
um baby step number three is where my
wife and I are at we've been married for
16 years we have five kids and legal
separation was proposed um she brought
it up the last night when we were
talking we have four thousand dollars to
the penny in our emergency fund right
now
and I think we've never established a
monthly budget but I think our net to
cover is between three thousand and
thirty five hundred dollars just to
survive so we have essentially A month's
worth of savings right now my question
for you is
should I add a second job to go gazelle
intense to bump up our savings or is it
more important to deal with my mental
health
and my marriage
in this season
also one part of this is my mental
health I was diagnosed with bipolar a
number of years ago I think five years
ago and I was just on a manic phase
yesterday oh my goodness are you seeing
someone or have you seen a counselor a
medical professional for this
I I am being treated by my team I have a
counselor that I see on a weekly basis I
have a psychiatrist where I think I
think five or six times in the last
three months and they're actively
managing my meds and I just had a
medication change just today and we're
trying to find the right balance for the
different mood stabilizers and the
different medications I think I've been
on so six or seven different medications
in the last four years I mean do you and
the team feel like there's progress that
has been made and that it's at least
while we're still testing and trying
that there's some progress I think I
think we're testing and trying I know
that uh in September I was I was
hospitalized twice one was voluntary the
other one was involuntary
and it's been it's been a hard life for
my wife just dealing with my moods and
uh she she's receiving counseling for
herself individually over the last year
and
she's not willing to go back to the
relationship that we used to have just
because it was unhealthy it's an
unhealthy Dynamic where she was trying
to regulate my moods with behaviors that
she would that she no I I don't know
yeah I don't want to be crass but she
would try and control me with sex by
giving me what I wanted and it was just
it was unhealthy yeah well so to answer
your question you need to be focusing on
your health and her health yes sir and
want to see you get you know that
emergency fund where it needs to be but
we we've got bigger issues at play right
now yeah I mean a situation like this if
it's heading towards divorce it turns
marriage into a business transaction and
so the goal at that point is to
obviously protect the kids that's the A1
and number two is to make this as little
of a mess as possible with the finances
and so how sure is this separation is
this something you guys are going to try
to work through or is this is this
headed south
well even legally or we've been
separated since November 10th of last
year so it's 11 months in
and it doesn't seem to make we haven't
seen much forward progress we've done
intensive marriage counseling weekend
week out for the last 12 weeks and
it was financially costing us 150 a
session and somebody at our chairs
established a bit of a fund for the
Higgins family
for us to receive 50 of that counseling
to cover when we were coming out of
pocket 75 a week and
it was a financial it was a pretty good
Financial ask on our on our part but we
were we didn't I can't I can't look back
and say that we've made progress in the
last few months I could say that times
are gone finally spent the money but we
haven't really made progress and then
you had the conversation last night
where she she brought up let's we need
to make this legal
yes sir so it doesn't look good and and
no and so at this point again the
emergency fund but but you taking a
second job if you've got the health to
do so I don't think that's a
I I don't I don't know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing but bringing in
more income during this season uh you
might be a right idea but I certainly
would check with your your uh
your medical team uh on this to see you
know do they feel like this is you know
adding more at work hours during this
transition is that healthy for you I I
ca we can't speak to that it feels like
it may not be yeah I mean you you guys
don't have debt and if this does head to
divorce then you know being married with
16 years five kids then it becomes who's
getting what and custody battles and all
that stuff and so I would I would be
looking at getting a lawyer to figure
this out if it's been 12 months with no
progress yeah
in five weeks it'll be 12 months so
we're not we're not on the 12-month Mark
yet but we're almost to the 11 month
Mark so it's like it's
but at that point I might look at
getting separate checking accounts
because the fear is one spouse drains
the account and runs and you don't have
any recourse
if things continue to go south it sounds
like it's been amicable which is great
and everyone's you know we're still
living you're living as roommates
essentially right for the last almost a
year we're we're not in the same
household okay
we're physically we're about three miles
apart where are the kids
Twitter off all four and then the fifth
one our second born as a difficult
relationship with her she's 11 years old
and she's living with her aunts okay I'm
just wondering what what's best long
term for the kids at this point what's
fair to them and living in this weird
Purgatory of our mom and dad together
not it's not official they're still
trying to work through this I'm just
more worried about the kids than
anything at this point and so I would
try to actually have some level of
closure to whatever this is it sounds
like we need to just call it if you've
been living apart for this long
I don't want to give up on it though
well I'm with you brother I I would so
back to the main point of your question
I mean if you've got to work and if you
can do it and and you've got to work to
to help pay for the counseling I'd fight
for the marriage I'd fight for I I will
tell you this just candidly
one of my closest friends in the world
went through divorce over a decade ago
and we were recently hanging out and and
it was an amicable divorce
um
but we were talking about another friend
of ours who's going through a divorce
right now and he told me my friend
that's been divorced now over a decade
he said I would tell him to fight with
every ounce in his body with everything
he's got left fight fight to save the
marriage because it is so destructive to
the kids to everybody so I I'm with you
man I'd summon every ounce of strength
I've got and and I would put some of
that strength into you doing everything
you can
to get healthy because a healthy you is
the best chance we have of having a
healthy marriage
but I'd fight I think
I'm I hear what you're saying and I want
to fight and
I one thing that specifically that she
said in the last week is that she wants
me to find the program to follow through
on the program and not to Short Circuit
the program and
yeah just the follow-through and the
consistency is what I need to show you
then do it on myself then do it okay do
it you can decide
you can decide right now do it show her
if you're gonna fight and you want to
fight then I'd say all right babe I'm
gonna do it and I'm gonna follow through
and show you that I want our marriage to
work hang on the line Grant we're going
to send you a copy of Dr John deloney's
book own your past change your future so
we can continue to walk with you through
this really tough situation thanks for
the call this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell join this hour bye my
friend Ken Coleman and Ken you were just
on your own show right before this one
the kid Pullman show helping folks find
those careers that they love and a lot
of people don't believe it's possible
they're not sure how to get there it's
all very squishy and you walk them
through a very clear process in those
calls yeah we do and uh you know it's as
simple as self-awareness you know an
aware person is very clear then on who
they are what they want to do why they
want to do it and then that translates
the confidence to step out and go after
it and then it gives you ultimately
courage to stay on the path we've got a
great tool that we develop based on that
methodology and the methodology is
simple if you use what you do best
talent to do work that you really love
that's passion to produce results that
you care deeply about that's a sense of
mission in when you use talent to
perform passion to produce your mission
you're on purpose and we've got a great
assessment of tens of thousands of
people have downloaded it's called the
get clear assessment I've got a printout
right here this is what you can actually
print out you have the digital version
as well I'm looking at mine right now
but you get a very nice detailed report
on
what you do best what work really fires
you up and then what results drive you
in other words motivates you it's called
the get clear assessment and it's
normally thirty dollars it's a 20 minute
assessment and you get a detailed report
plus a a a very clear purpose statement
that's filled in with those top three
talents top three passions and that
primary motivational driver that we call
Mission and it's now ten dollars at
ramseysolutions.com there's no
assessment like it there's there there's
other assessments that measure talent
but nothing that measures what you love
and then what motivates you and so
you've got to understand Talent is a
tool but it is Passion which is love and
then Mission which is what motivates me
that's the heart
so 20 minute assessment it's a great
gift
um it is great for a variety of people
people who feel stuck people who feel
like they've got no clue what they want
to do people who have a really good idea
and they want to get some clarity and
confidence that that is in fact the
mountain they want to climb so they get
clear assessment it's only ten dollars
in the month of October right now
ramseysolutions.com that's a killer deal
I've taken it myself and I'm looking at
it right now and it was spot on it was
like you were reading my mail Ken see
there it is it says you were created to
use your talents of imagination
communication and discernment to perform
your passions of promoting leading and
creating to accomplish your mission of
creation by producing new things and
ideas I couldn't have said it better
myself so that becomes a high-level job
description and so you want to be able
to spend 75 percent of your day
living that purpose statement out and
you are my friend I love to create it's
a lot of fun and it gives you possible
Industries based on your results and
look at this it's got education and
motivational speaking and writing it's
got everything I'm doing Ken so I feel
like I'm in my sweet spot well you
confirmed it you are and not only you're
in your sweet spot you look fantastic in
your little bomber jacket it's a little
bomber well it is you're a little guy
and to be fair it is an extra small you
wouldn't want to wear a big bomber
jacket that's true yeah well uh before
we Ken digs me any further I'm going to
mention that you can go get that uh get
clear assessment for just 10 bucks at
ramsaysolutions.com hurry up it won't
last long so thank you well actually
it'll last forever you know why it's a
digital we never run out that's true
well unless the Internet by the way you
don't have to pay shipping or handling
you know why it's digital it's digital
thank you for the my mom listening
she'll be like oh that's helpful Ken
thank you that's great that's that's my
demographic she's always listening all
right let's go to the phones if you've
got questions about how to advance in
your career switch careers side hustles
increase that income Ken is here for you
and I can help jump in on those money
questions the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five Andrew
is jumping in next in Cincinnati Ohio
Andrew welcome to the show
foreign
hey
how you doing this is awesome can you
hear me okay yeah loud and clear Andrew
you're live on the Ramsay show how can
we help oh dude sweet anyway so this is
kind of a student loan question there's
layers of this so if I you if you ask me
questions if you feel like I need to
clarify right
um in the end I don't know oh about
thirty nine thousand dollars in student
loans
um so 12 000 of that is to my parents
and then there's about three or like
four or five of them that are just
federal student loans
um my my father decided it was like a
Parent PLUS Loan and he decided that he
wanted to pay off the loan
um about two or three years ago
and now he um I'm in a situation with
work when I'm earning a lot more money
than I used to and I won't be able to
pay off these loans a lot faster and
then went on top of Biden doing their
ten thousand dollars you know and if I
was going to go ahead and I'll take it
to the basket you know what I'm saying
so I am um
that was a sports reference yeah we just
went to SportsCenter there I want to
address that in a minute but keep going
what's your question
so the question is is so my dad wanted
went ahead and paid off that student
loan and now that I'm in a situational
work when I'm making a lot more money
um he he was telling me that he he wants
that money back right rightfully so and
so I'm stuck in between this should I go
ahead and do the
um the baby steps for the student loans
or should I go ahead and pay off my dad
first which is the biggest one and get
rid of that slave master relationship
um
that's interesting so you're saying hey
should I do the debt snowball as is even
though the 12 000 is at the very end of
it but Dad's hanging over my neck going
hey I want this money back how much does
he need this money versus it just being
a moral hey I paid this off but it was
for you I'd like the money back
is he in a tough Financial spot
no he's he's not he honestly he's he's
told me that dude it could be like two
three four years like it's fine
um so he's like this is not like every
time he's on the phone he's like Hey
where's my loan money at no no no no no
nothing like that but then this goes
back to the work part of things is that
I'm in this situation where I'm able to
pay off a lot more money within the next
like 18 weeks but the money's not going
to last forever so it's either pay off
the Federal loans and just like
they just do the debt snowball just
smallest to largest and you'll get there
a lot faster and then when you get to
the end time to pay dad back and you're
done with this whole thing within what a
year
well so no so Vegas it is working to get
a little confusing is that I so I'm a
respiratory therapist shout out restore
therapist
um and because of um coven and all that
stuff they're really desperate for
nurses and respiratory therapists and
doctors in all Healthcare World
um and so they're paying me an extra
about 60 an hour which would be about
ninety dollars an hour
um which makes a lot of disposable
income after this
um but after all this is done and
they're like all right gravy trains over
get off you know like I only have about
three four hundred dollars left of to go
towards debt and that's what I'm saying
that's fourteen thousand dollars is it's
going to be there for a long time
so how long will it take to pay off your
debt making this extra money you're
making right now thirty nine thousand
how quickly can you pay that off
making this
if you're interested so
let's see
so I'll be honest I haven't really
looked at yeah yeah can I can I jump in
Hey listen bro let me let me help you
out there's nothing confusing about what
you threw at us nothing I kept waiting
for the confusing part the only thing
that's confusing
it's not layers you'd use the debt
snowball make an extra income right
there's a season in your in your work
life where you you got a boon of income
I mean it's it's it's it's kind of
booming for a while yes you attack it
faster right but it's not like as a
respiratory therapist you're not going
to have an opportunity to make more
money elsewhere
um and and and you act like you know the
income's gonna go away and you'll never
be able to get a raise or move up I mean
you're thinking too hard you stop you
just work the snowball work the debt
snowball smallest to largest intense
second job third job whatever you got to
do gazelle intense whatever that looks
like for you to pay every loan back
including your debt and honestly you'll
get there I think a lot quicker than you
realize this is not an insta
intermountable amount of debt and you
can do this it's not going to be there
forever and and you just have to stop
thinking so much and get busy how much
money do you have in the bank right now
Andrew
[Music]
um we're going on about about seven
thousand okay we're taking six of that
just throw it this debt we're gonna take
this amazing income you have to clean up
the rest we're paying dad back and all
of a sudden 12 months from now no
excuses you're completely debt free with
a fully funded emergency fund it's that
simple no layers George this was not
that this was not a Tiramisu cat it was
not that complicated not that many
layers we're shooting for you man just
don't overthink it you got this one
thing at a time Focus intensity and
you'll be debt free in no time this is
the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm George camel he's Ken Coleman this
is the Ramsay show you can give us a
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five Brian is joining us from
Houston Texas Brian welcome to the show
all right thank you guys for having me
absolutely what's going on
all right so um I'm 27 years old my wife
is 25 and we have a three week old at
home
and
um my basic my question is are we doing
baby step four correctly we've been on
the Ramsey plan for a little over a year
now and this is my current situation I
contributed six percent to my company's
401k and they match 50 of that to reach
the other nine percent my wife and I are
planning on opening up a Roth IRA for
each of us my wife was a teacher for two
years and has nine thousand dollars in
her teacher retirement account called
TRS we plan on rolling that over to a
Roth and paying the taxes then to open
up a Roth for me we have to have six
thousand dollars to start the account
does it make sense to open up my account
before year ends 2022 so we can
contribute monthly up to six thousand
dollars in 2023 to meet our nine percent
hmm
well you wouldn't roll into a Roth and
create a tax burden until you're in baby
step seven with a paid for house
and so I would roll that to a
traditional IRA in order to avoid taxes
okay on on my wife's portion yes
and that's just so that we're in control
and you can still invest in that
traditional IRA or you can then open up
a new Roth IRA and use future funds
towards that and that wouldn't create a
tax burden
okay so you would use after tax dollars
uh is she so she's not working outside
the home right now is she with the three
week old
yes so she's so she's not teaching
anymore she's going to stay at home with
the baby okay and what's your income
gross
um my current is uh 69 000 but with uh
bonuses the bonuses are pretty generous
it's usually between an extra six and
fifty thousand a year six and fifty
yeah it's a pretty I'm in the oil and
gas so when Times Are Good Times Are
Good
yes sir okay so the easiest thing to do
with that kind of a regular income with
bonuses just invest 15 of your income of
whatever it is that month and so you can
do that you said six percent uh is what
you're doing now and they match 50 is it
up to a certain amount they match or
they match all the way
um so that up to that six percent so
they put in I guess three percent of my
income you could say okay so that six
percent gets you up to the match then
you can fully fund a Roth IRA
Q that's another six thousand
okay
and then does she have earned income at
that point
no no she's she's staying at home okay
so you could go back to the 401K
as well as funding a traditional or a
Roth so you would open up a new Roth for
her at that point we just don't want to
roll the traditional plan she had into a
Roth because that is when the tax burden
would hit it'll just be taxable income
so I would open up a new Roth for her
what's that
should I see what you're saying so the
nine just to a traditional and then open
up a new rock for her exactly
and you should have a 6 000 Inlet on
that for the year
okay and when we open up a rock for me
yes
and then if they're still you haven't
hit 15 you can go back to that 401k and
finish it out there
okay I see I see what you're saying yeah
I was I was curious because I I figured
I was like well I should probably open
it up for me this year at that 6 000 so
that I can contribute to it next year
because if I start it at least this is
what my financial I I talked to uh one
of the smart master pros and he said
well if you start it at the 6000 in
January you can't contribute to it all
year
yeah it might be something you have to
just start later on then
if you can't do it retroactively
so yeah I think you've got it down man
you guys are doing great and congrats on
the three week old that's exciting yeah
get some sleep
I'm surprised you're this sharp with a
three week old yeah I think you're
extremely coherent my friend that's uh
that's a tough season impressed yeah but
I love it
I think I cut them off George I'm sorry
Brian are you still with us did I cut
you off buddy
yeah I'm sorry I was saying I'm married
to an amazing woman who's been married a
nerd so I wanted to hear that he married
an amazing woman who married a nerd but
you know what could you sing the same
thing about you and your situation my
situation you know both of our wives
have horrible judgment and thus we are
married fool them yeah we do love it
yeah all right we're going to the great
city of Scranton Pennsylvania up next
with our friend John John what's going
on
uh I have I sold my silver route of 3500
that was paid off and then I paid in
cash for a Peterbilt
and I want to know if it's okay while
I'm babysit too to save up a repair fund
for the Peterbilt of 50 Grand
why are you 50 grand for that
the uh Peterbilt is new to me it has 835
000 miles and caterpillars the engine
recommends a engine overhaul at a
million miles
engine overhaul according to Peterbilt
costs uh thirty two thousand dollars
so is this rig is this for your business
yep just started it okay and it's paid
for
yes but you now have a fifty thousand
dollar repair on this thing
uh uh potentially right now it runs fine
but uh adding another 150 000 miles to
it it's probably gonna happen in four or
five months okay and how much debt do
you have
I have seventy two thousand and what is
that
uh 68 000 on solar panels and then four
thousand remaining on a personal loan
that I'm almost done with
okay what's the business
and you sold the the the Chevy Silverado
to buy the Peterbilt to haul the water
yes you were hauling it in the Silverado
before
no I I'm I was working for a different
uh uh a different company hauling it in
a Kenworth for another person and I
decided to go owner operator so I sold
my paid in full Silverado do you have
another car for personal use yes and
that's paid for as well how much water
are we dragging around
130 barrels
have you made money with this business
yet is it profitable
uh I start on the 17th
okay and it's just you or do you have a
team
it's just me right now
okay and your first gig is on the 17th
yes is there another way sorry for the
simplistic question but I'm going
somewhere with this is there another way
to drag the water around then then the
old truck
and I mean like a wagon or something
forgive me but is there something of a
trailer that's a whole lot less money
and doesn't have all the mechanical
issues
uh
yeah thanks for the question uh the
Frack companies take at a minimum 110
barrels at a time
is there a seventy thousand pounds so no
a Silverado it's something smaller
cannot do it okay you can't pull it in a
trailer
no no it's uh way overweight okay I got
you all right forgive me I I don't know
anything about that stuff at all okay so
your your question is Cash flowing this
during baby step two
yeah saving it up for a repair
should he save up the emergency fund
yeah this would be like saving reserves
for your business at that point yes sir
and so if this is an emergency where the
truck won't run right now then yes and
you know it's going to happen but I
would get some clarity on when it's
going to happen and how much that's
going to cost and then kind of create
that sinking fund and if that's ten
thousand twenty thousand a month I don't
know how much this business is going to
bring in do you have any idea
I should have the 50 Grand in uh within
10 weeks oh wonderful I tell you what
I'd also be looking to find the best
most affordable reputable mechanic that
works on these things and get in a
second opinion as well and what can you
do along the way maybe to try to avoid
uh the uh recommended engine replacement
at million miles I'd be doing everything
I could to save from preventative
maintenance as well yeah but I would
you're gonna have to stockpile that kind
of cash in your reserves for your
business on top of then starting to
clean up the debt and create your own
emergency fund for your personal life
and so that's part of being a small
business owner but uh I wish you the
best with this new business man that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Ken Coleman all the
folks in the booth Jenna Ben James
Austin Zach Andrew the whole gang and
you America thanks for listening we'll
be back with you before you know
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsey show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world to get
your daily dose of advice on life and
money check out all of our shows from
the Ramsay Network wherever you listen
to podcasts
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell join this hour bye my friend
Ken Coleman and we are here for you to
take your call to give you some hope and
all kinds of areas of life maybe it's
money maybe it's your career a toxic
work situation a bad debt situation we
want to help the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five John kicks us off in Pensacola John
welcome to the show
uh hey how are y'all doing we are doing
great what's going on with you
uh well I was working for a previous
employer uh for approximately four to
five months they gave me a pretty good
um starting starting bonus package and I
worked there for a while but it wasn't a
great work environment I didn't really
enjoy it and I thought I'd be better at
my previous job so I decided to leave I
understood I was gonna have to pay back
my starting uh package which I you know
I was more than willing to do but
they've kind of tacked on a whole lot of
other fees which I feel are really
exorbitant and now I'm kind of stuck
paying back my previous employer with
way more than what they gave me in the
starting bonus package was this all in
writing what you would have to pay back
I did have to sign a contract payment I
would have to pay back uh you know some
of the moving fees and stuff like that
at the very beginning but it was way way
way more than what I thought it was
going to be okay but what I'm getting at
is is is it laid out very clearly in
that agreement
to where what they're asking you to pay
back is clearly by the letter of the
agreement okay not included or is it
just it's included uh but you just
thought it would be less money that's
what I'm trying to get to
I gotcha and the original agreement it
really just kind of said that you're
trying to pay back the money that we
gave you plus the moving expenses and uh
things of that nature it doesn't really
give out a outlined amount or anything
like that okay so so the expenses that
they are now wanting you to pay back
they fall within the categories written
very clearly in the agreement
uh I would say yes but they're they're
way way more they're like almost twice
as much
so you have receipts of what you
actually so my point is you have
Financial records to be able to dispute
that what they're asking is more than
they actually paid you
um yeah kind of so I guess I'll put it
this way like so uh they gave me a
starting point I'll give you the numbers
if you don't mind sure yeah they gave me
a starting bonus of like sixteen
thousand dollars and I was like okay
cool and they moved me from North
Alabama down to Florida where I am now
um and you know I left the company like
I said after about five months and now
they're trying to say I can pay them
back 34 000 and I was you know kind of
flabbergasted at that number I thought I
was going to pay back maybe 16 plus
moving costs of like maybe maybe twenty
thousand dollars all together but
they're talking about thirty five
thousand dollars what was the signing
bonus
yeah
16k and then the relocation costs
the relocation cost is what I think is
kind of kind of crazy there because I'm
looking at these the numbers now they're
saying that it costs um
about seven thousand dollars to move
from from North Alabama down to Florida
in Pensacola Florida which is not even
down to the Panhandle near Miami it's
close to uh you know it's close to
Alabama
yes so did they pay you seven thousand
dollars does that end up in your bank
account no sir that was just how much
they say it cost to move that far
well they so they paid it directly with
the moving company
correct
I uh having moved you know from
Georgia to Tennessee I don't that
doesn't sound crazy it doesn't sound
like it's off much
um but again you need to be asking for
receipts so the 16 and the signing bonus
the seven and relocation where's the
rest of this 34 coming from
yeah and the rest of the guy I'm looking
at the thing here they they uh they had
me in temporary lodging for a little
while before I found a an apartment down
here okay they're thinking that uh
the temporary lodging was five thousand
dollars for just one month and
and uh let me see here I mean that
sounds fair for temporary if that's you
know corporate rents or Corporate
Lodging is more expensive than a
traditional rent
yeah that's 166 bucks a night okay
I just stayed in the basic Hotel you
know so I was just yeah I mean you got
to ask them you got to ask them to show
you all the receipts of this stuff if
they will I mean if you're gonna dispute
it you you got to have some facts
I gotcha yeah what was the agreement was
if you stayed a certain amount of time
you don't have to pay it back exactly
and it was like I want to say two years
or one I can't remember if it was one or
two years but it's going over two years
yeah it sounds like
there you didn't do your due diligence
and homework and reading all the fine
print and figuring it out and they're
covering all these expenses and it's not
up to you to do the research and make
sure that it's affordable you were just
kind of like all right they're covering
the costs
um but at the same time you sign an
agreement saying if you leave under
those two years you owe us all the money
back yeah so it stinks it I would put
this under I would file it under stupid
tax
and it may be one of those money
mistakes where you go man that sucked I
have to pay that back I mean you can try
to fight it and do civil lawsuit I just
don't think you have much of a much
ground to stand on if they've got all
their receipts which I assume they do
I yeah I gotcha I actually did hire uh a
lawyer to see if they can kind of defeat
this for like a thousand dollar retainer
and he's trying to help me out here uh
but you know I don't know if I can get
them out much lower I might be able to
settle with them and pay a smaller
amount
that's probably best case scenario
yeah because I'm willing to pay the of
course at 16 and I'm in something else
of course on top of that but I just
didn't want to pay the full 30 34. uh to
be honest with you I agree with George I
would propose a settlement you know but
uh based on the numbers that you've
given us so far it doesn't sound like
you're getting gouged sounds like
they're they're listing out every single
expense and they probably have receipts
because they're a legitimate company and
so at that point there's not much to
fight
um yeah okay you guys are
oh I mean it sucks I'm not trying to
belittle that this really is not a fun
situation
um and I'm rooting for John but at this
point it's one of those dang it should
have read that fine print should have
asked more questions should have asked
them where they're lodging me because I
don't know if this is going to work out
over there but it sounds like to me they
gave you a detailed printout or they
gave you a detailed layout of the 34
000. it all equals up to thirty four
thousand correct
yeah that's correct I'm looking at it
now yep ma'am I I mean that's what I'd
be asking for and you got it so you know
uh unless you can somehow prove that
they're price gouging it kind of feels
like a medical bill where like you don't
know what the procedure is costing and
what insurance is and then all of a
sudden you're like oh my gosh yeah I
have a 34 000 medical bill yeah that's
about what it feels like too and that's
kind of what I'm looking at you because
I've personally moved across the country
before and and it cost me 2 500 with all
my stuff to move that's John doing at
John's way with John's research and John
choosing the company this is a company
who is flush with cash it's probably
also some movers that are wearing weight
belts instead of proper back support oh
yeah oh yeah you know like they rented a
truck that's not I mean 2500 to move
across country that might have been 30
years ago oh yeah boy oh boy it's
expensive to move these days John that
stinks and for those listening who are
entering into a situation like that do
your due diligence and think about what
if this doesn't go to plan maybe I
should have this money set aside until
those two years are over in case this
thing goes south and that just puts you
in a better Financial spot than where we
find our friend John by the way that's
why you should also be using PODS moving
in storage Great
calls they're not gonna they're not
gonna cost you an arm and a lot
that's a saying Ken is it I gotta teach
Ken's lingo I'm sorry hey more of that
lingo coming up right here on the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
folks the stock market has been rough
lately and if you've been watching your
Investments take a hit it sucks I get it
but if you're freaking out don't Market
dips don't mean you have to retire broke
you've got to keep a long-term
perspective and remember that investing
is a marathon not a Sprint so look at
the facts if you invest 120 dollars a
month from age 25 to 65 you could have
over a million dollars for retirement no
it's not too good to be true that's
based on the long-term average return of
the S P 500 which is the top 500
American companies now if you're not 25
you're a little older than that that's
okay it's not too late you got to get
started though no matter what age you
start investing you'll be happy you did
when it's time to retire in fact a huge
predictor of investing success is that
you actually invest shocker I know and
you keep investing consistently so get a
pro in your corner to help you get
started to find one who can help you
invest with confidence just go to
ramseysolutions.com smartvest master and
we'll connect you with smartvester Pros
in your area who can help you make a
plan for your goals and guide you
through the ups and downs of the market
again ramseysolutions.com smartvestor
Jack joins us up next in Montana Jack
welcome to the show
thank you thank you what's going on
taking my call well I inherited ninety
five thousand dollars
um 58 years old my wife is 63.
um we bought a house
and I want to get it paid off we bought
it for
280. we owe 195.
um we have 36
595.60 in the bank that's not towards
your bills we have no credit card debt
we haven't had any debt three years
um I'll I'll go back to my story on so
you can get a little just 17 years ago
or actually 20 years ago I got divorced
at fifty thousand dollars in debt
um focused on that and now I'm sitting
with the money in the bank
two hundred and eighty thousand dollars
in a 401k
um and I the only debt I have is the 195
000 on the house cool my question is is
I would like to take that ninety five
thousand dollars and just put it down on
my house and that gets me down to a
hundred thousand with what we've been
doing our house will be paid off in five
years
um without a doubt
um I got other people saying no don't do
that because I'll have to pay twelve
thousand dollars in taxes if I take that
money out for income taxes
if you take the inherited money yeah you
inherited yes I take that inheritance
inherited money I'm gonna have to pay
income tax I'm not gonna hurt about it
okay um which is roughly about twelve
thousand dollars as well
um other people are saying and I talked
to a financial advisor I can invest it
on a 13 13 month CD or whatever at like
four percent interest of course a
financial advisor is going to want you
to invest it instead of paying your
house down so that's not a reputable
Source in that regard I'm paying the
taxes on it and putting it on the house
and puts you closer to what 112 on the
mortgage yeah yeah and let's still make
it a goal to pay it off in five years
and that money in the bank that you have
is that your emergency fund with a
little more yeah yeah a little more and
and we drive that's the other thing is
we drive old cars I haven't bought a car
um but we can't water can't we don't go
out of town much if I do go on a trip I
just rent a car I figure it's smarter
than having that payment every month if
you borrowed money I could take the 36
000 and we thought about this because my
wife is 63 like I said I'm 58 with the
car prices today we do need a new car so
when we retire we will have a vehicle
and we've thought about taking twenty
thousand dollars of that thirty six
thousand dollars and buying a car that
we can rely on what's your household
income
uh what is it I got it written down here
um 95 000. okay
great my wife is retired that's 95 000
before I put 15 in a 401k we put 250 in
this evening you know we keep adding to
that money okay um so I would I would
separate your emergency fund so separate
your emergency fund have your three to
six months and then have a different
savings account for your car upgrade and
buy a reasonable used car with cash and
I'm paying this house down and I'm gonna
make that a goal because it's going to
be hard to retire with a mortgage
hanging over your head and you've got
280 in your 401k you're gonna need more
than that to live on and so at least
without a house payment you can limit
your expenses and so you have you don't
need much to live on in retirement so
that's that's what I would do if I was
in your shoes and I would ignore those
other people because other people are
broke and everyone's got an opinion but
this is your money in your life and
having no mortgage payment changes
everything so appreciate the call
all right up next we are going to
Charlotte North Carolina Brandon joins
us there Brandon welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me guys sure
what's going on uh yeah so I just we
just moved to North Carolina actually
and we are in the process of trying to
figure out what Auto Insurance
to use and I'm just not super familiar
should we do full coverage uh liability
obviously there's tons even in within
that so I would love to hear some of
your thoughts on auto coverage yeah I
mean you definitely want liability
you're going to want comprehensive and
you're going to want collision and
uninsured motorist is very important too
that one can tank some people
and a really easy way to do this what's
that
I said I worked with one of your um elps
and they had just kind of given me two
quotes one with full coverage and one
with limited liability and I was like I
don't know which one to pick so yeah I
mean I would go with the full coverage
because these situations can put people
in a real pickle when they are
underinsured and I've been there uh this
was about I don't know eight nine years
ago I got in a car wreck and I didn't
have great coverage I was still in my
parents insurance and I was underinsured
and we ended up getting sued and luckily
I didn't have to pay anything out of
pocket but this was three years of
nightmares hanging over my head going am
I gonna have to you know go out of
pocket for this and she ended up getting
50 Grand between the two insurance
companies her own and mine and so that
was a scary moment and from then on I
made sure that I had as much coverage as
I could get that made sense for me
so did they walk you through the options
of what it looks like to have full
coverage versus limited liability
not really he just kind of sent the two
I mean it's broken down in terms of what
it covers and how much and those kinds
of things but we never really talked
about it he just sent it over so I
wasn't sure because I was like man we
drive to hoopties if you will and um
well my wife's car is less of a hoopty
but it's like the cars aren't worth that
much so it's really about just other
people's medical then versus replacing
your car
yeah yeah
um
well I mean when you have limited
liability collision and comprehensive
that's what full coverage is and I would
recommend all three so if you can swing
it can you can you cover the expense
what's the difference between them yeah
uh we're talking like 117 versus like 71
so it's not like a huge difference we're
just we're really getting up in the pace
of going like both of us getting on the
same page and feeling like I don't know
it just was like a small thing that I
was just like uh but that's like an
extra 40 bucks I can go somewhere kind
of thing yeah
well in this process we're gonna we're
starting uh starting a company uh we're
starting business and so that's been fun
and but you know there's just expenses
there so I feel like we're cutting in
all these spots so I just wouldn't
compare there you don't want to cut
there 40 bucks I got a subscription then
cutting into my uh Insurance that's
right so if you can get a good rate on
full coverage I'm going for it and that
sounds very reasonable
sweet okay so and you can get a second
opinion on that but I've got full
coverage and I sleep better at night and
that's worth the extra you know 20 30
bucks
and you don't sleep well as it is right
terrible sleep issues but one thing I
don't worry about is insurance and there
are so many types of Insurance Ken I
know you your brain just melts a little
bit having to talk about insurance for
too long here we go people with the
types of crazy Insurance stores you love
this and actually I love it too because
it's quite entertaining it's like a it
could have been a top 10 list on
Letterman yeah we covered what do we got
I did a tick tock on this cat there was
something about aliens there was alien
abduction Insurance alien abduction
Insurance my personal favorite my
favorite is the the pet Rapture
Insurance where atheists will take care
of your pets if you die and you're a
Christian and you get raptured The
Atheist said hey for the low price of 10
bucks a month I'll make sure Fido's
covered it's this kind of crap that
makes Christians look and look bad
that's that's just ridiculous well Ken I
did a five day video series that's
completely free to help folks get more
confidence in their coverage you can go
sign up for that at ramseysolutions.com
confidence you'll get an email every day
with a quick three minute video and by
the end you're gonna be a pro even Ken
can do this stuff oh thanks to you yeah
I'm here for you Ken and don't buy alien
infection insurance no we don't
recommend that goes down we got bigger
problems all right more of your calls
coming up on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsay personality George Campbell Ken
Coleman co-hosting today this is your
show America give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five Laura
joins us up next in Knoxville Tennessee
or welcome to the show
absolutely how can we help today
um
I'm passed away
um in December of last year
I took a little bit of time off from
work thank you I took a little time off
from work
um after that
um and I returned to work but at reduced
hours so well I had been working a
regular 40-hour week I'm now working a
32-hour week so of course my
annual salary is adjusted
um yeah for that
um and I'm just curious if that's
something that I can afford to do long
term
um you know planning for the future now
is is quite a bit different than it was
this time last year so I'm a little
stumped on on how to proceed from here
sure well we can walk through some of
these numbers and give you some peace
about that but I just want to say I'm so
sorry yes for your loss how old was he
uh he was 47 and I'm 41. oh my goodness
much too young
yeah
well let's walk through some of these
numbers so what are you making right now
with that 32 hours a week
uh right now I'm at 51 000 per year he
said 61 or 51.
51. okay
and is that enough to cover your bills
oh yeah definitely okay so you have some
margins I'm pretty Frugal so that's good
do you have any debt
uh I have a car
um a car loan that I owe about 8 500 on
that's going to be paid off this month
oh good okay and that's it for debt
and that's it nothing else how much do
you have in the bank
liquid cash um I've got a I've got about
45 000 in retirement 403b
um I've got 35
000 in a mutual fund
I've got about 40 000 in a savings
account and I'm working on selling about
uh somewhere between 75 and 100 000
worth of
assets and things like that yeah and is
that mutual fund is that just in a
taxable brokerage account it's
non-retirement
correct a lot of retirement account what
would you think about cashing that out
um so I don't know how it's performing
or anything just yet I think I've had it
open for maybe three months okay and
then George let me just ask a quick
question here the margin uh on your 32
hours when you get paid uh how much
margin do you have I know you're Frugal
uh how much do you have left over after
all the bills
uh well I automatically will put half of
my paycheck in the savings account and
half of it covers
everything that I that I need to pay
plus some I usually add a little extra
okay so that's what I thought and the
reason that I asked that is really to
address your initial question
which is you know how long can you
afford to keep working 32 hours a week
if I understood you correctly yeah and
the answer is you can afford to do it
now you're comfortable my goodness I
mean you get 40 000 in savings I know
what George is going to tell you about
paying off that car today
yeah well that's sort of the plan
um I've been as I've been selling things
that that savings account jumped that
really really quickly I think you can
afford to work 32 hours a week as long
as you choose to
okay you're not you're not silly you're
in great financial position wouldn't you
say George oh yeah you said you're 41.
yes
Okay so we've got an investment
calculator over at ramseysolutions.com I
want you to play with that and then get
in touch with the smart Master Pro to
help you create a retirement goal
because crunching the numbers here
you're 41 at 61. you said you have 45
000 in retirement
and let's say we were able to add you
think you could add 800 a month to that
oh easily okay so at a nine percent
return over that 20 years it'll become
eight hundred thousand now my goal for
you would be to have over a million so
that you can retire fairly comfortably
with net without a house payment do you
have a mortgage right now
no house is paid for wow what's that
worth it that's awesome
um in this market it's probably worth
about 275. okay yeah you're in great
shape so if you've got no payments in
the world after you pay off this car
today which I'm so excited for you to do
as soon as you get off the phone Laura
right
yes okay
you know we should do we should do it
sometime we phone in right now another
line we call the lender right now and
you pay it over the phone and we
celebrate that we couldn't do that
because we wouldn't want to reveal her
to her her bank account info that would
be fun that's true it would be fun to
pay it off on the air
so James we got to figure out how to do
that sometime
yeah he's on it he's working on it so
Laura if you did let's say 900 a month
and you worked till 63 you would have
over a million and that's with a nine
percent return uh which is reasonable
and so I have a lot of faith that you
can retire with a lot of dignity
especially because you don't have a
house payment without question and your
income is only going to go up over 20
years right yeah even if you remain at
32 hours and so you're in great shape
and you've got 35 in the mutual fund
you're going to sell off these assets uh
you can invest that money once you sell
those assets as well since you already
have a paid for a house your next goal
is just to continue to build wealth be
generous and also spend some money and
enjoy your life I know you're Frugal
which tells me you probably don't have a
lot of quote fun
no I do what do you do for fun that
costs money
that costs money I have a
I have a third time when's the last time
you did that
um a couple of months ago okay awesome
look at George trying to spend your
money I'm trying to have some fun I got
your back over here I'm not gonna let
him get crazy with your money well I'm
I'm excited for the future Laura I know
the the past has been dark for you but
I'm hoping for brighter things ahead and
a great retirement so good thank you so
much for the proud of her yeah I mean
now let's just I want to pause here and
just point out that Laura having
Financial Peace to the level that she
does certainly helps when you when you
when you lose a spouse oh yeah that's
that is so devastating it's hard enough
on its own but then to add on to that
Financial stress how am I going to pay
the bills yeah she's going to be fine
and and uh I love that she's traveling
and and getting back out there and doing
life and wow tough stuff 45. it's heavy
too soon all right we're gonna take a
quick one from Amanda here Amanda get
straight to your question how can we
help today
yeah so my husband and I are coming into
about twenty thousand dollars here in
the next few days and um we're just
wondering how to best apply it to our
baby steps we've we're on baby step two
but we've had some recent vehicle
trouble and so we are not sure exactly
what we need to do are the vehicles in
the shop
s well they're not in the shop so we
have the vehicle situation actually
under control right now but there's one
that still needs a little bit of work
um but they're both very much hoopties
um one's a 2008 Dodge Caravan the other
one's a 2001 Lexus RX 300. okay and how
much debt do you have
we have about 32 000 left what kind of
debt is it
it is some student loans a the rest of
our timeshare that is that I don't want
to talk about it and
um a little bit on a credit card okay I
would continue doing that at snowball
how much do you guys have in the bank in
cash
um we have our thousand dollar emergency
fund and
um I mean I just got paid today so we
have a little bit more than that I
suppose but
um that's for the monthly bills and
stuff okay well you can create a sinking
fund in your budget for these car
repairs but I would not go out and buy
uh you know ten thousand dollar car
tomorrow because you're worried about
what could happen with these cars so I
would create a sinking fund where you
say all right we're gonna put a hundred
bucks away every month into a savings
account to cover this car repair because
a year from now we're probably gonna
have a thousand dollar repair on our
hands right and if you do have a repair
pause the debt snowball cash flow it
work side jobs whatever you got to do to
cash flow it and then get back on the
wagon and continue that dead snowball
but pay them off smallest to largest
with that 20 grand and uh don't let it
derail you with this kind of car these
car troubles
all right well thank you absolutely
thanks so much for the call more of your
calls coming up give us one triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
George camel he's Ken Coleman this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
first Timothy 1 5. the aim of our charge
is love that issues from a pure heart
and a good conscience and a sincere
faith
Abraham Lincoln said perhaps a man's
character is like a tree and his
reputation like its shadow the shadow is
what we think of it the tree is the real
thing
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman the sour open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jane joins us up next in Houston Texas
Jane welcome to the show
hey guys thanks so much for having me I
appreciate it absolutely how can Ken and
I help
so
wow
um it's a real bummer because
corporations have gone up significantly
since we bought the car
luckily he
was really diligent in finding comps and
so Insurance paid us properly in my
opinion
um
given that we had a ten thousand dollar
note on a car at the time it was stolen
and so now we've taken away 26
000 from insurance
um the loans paid off and we have 26 000
sitting in the bank we can't buy the
same car with that 26 000. I don't
really want to take on more debt
um currently we're a one-car family and
it's kind of Weighing on us we both work
really long hours but different
schedules kind of I mean really the same
schedule but we both just depending on
our days at work have different hours
basically
um I might have to work till eight
o'clock at night he will get done at 6
30 or vice versa just depending on
um the day so it's been a lot of uber a
lot of ubering basically my question is
do we just buy a junker hold on James
the difference from a junker to a thirty
thousand dollar car is very large
there's a spectrum there yeah why not
buy a 20 000 car is that a junker to you
well I guess I don't know I don't really
know what we could find for twenty
thousand dollars our answer is no
replacement twenty thousand dollar cars
how what's your income
um combined we make about three ten okay
and so for y'all a twenty thousand
dollar car is a junker because you make
that much money I am on uh I feel bad
because I have a really nice car so it's
so bad where is your money going Jane
that you can't afford to cash flow a
thirty thousand dollar car
um well we can afford a thirty thousand
dollar car but we can't afford
I guess like we couldn't afford to
replace him his car with the Tahoe that
he had before yeah but we're not doing
that we're not doing that what George is
saying about me I I okay first of all
you got to go to basic car website
Facebook Marketplace and just look in
your area uh in a budget range of 20
just through 20 and or fifteen thousand
I mean depending on what your financial
goals are but do you guys
we do we have student loans yeah okay
how much
uh about 97 000. yeah but look at a ten
thousand dollar car a 15 if you're
trying to cut back and use some of that
cash to go to the student loans I guess
that's what I was asking is should we
buy like a ten thousand dollar car and
put the rest of it towards the student
loans yes or should we love that plan
yes because that car is not your Forever
car that might be a one-year car and you
sell it and you upgrade once you're
completely debt free with an emergency
fund and you can easily cash flow a 35
000 car making 310.
once you have no debt right
yeah that's what we could save up for
one at least why don't you go on again
go online and just search cars between
seven and ten thousand and just see
what's out there you don't even know
trust me I know the reason I know is I
gotta I got a kid who needs a car all
right uh a teenager and so I've been
looking I'm looking all the time you'll
be surprised what you can get that's
highly functional
I'm pulling up just Tahoes and seeing in
my area what I can get for twenty
thousand dollars for example but we're
not doing 20 George we've already got
her down to 10. well even down to 15 you
can get a 2013 Tahoe so I think the
problem is expectations versus reality
you just don't know and that's not being
negative you just haven't looked you got
to look but you guys had a brand new
Tahoe pretty much what was the year on
it it was a 2016. okay so 2016 going
down to a 2013 feels like a downgrade
and that's hard emotionally for you guys
but she's looking at a sedan I'm telling
you my thing Jane is I think you guys
need to take control of your income and
go where is this 310 000 going because
if we can clean up we've been cash
flowing uh different project recently
and so that's kind of where some of it's
been going okay and we're we're able to
shift back now to our debts but we're
just trying to figure out what do we do
with this pile of cash do we buy a car
or do we stay a one-car family I think
you need the two cars you need a car you
spent the first two minutes in distress
over the one car it's not worth it you
guys make three hundred ten thousand
dollars get a reasonable car for now pay
off the debt get the emergency fund and
then we can upgrade the car yeah
okay that's simple simple simple simple
and yes it's going to take some
swallowing of the pride to go I don't
really love this car it's okay it's a
car it gets from A to B without having
to do Uber that's it yeah
so but that stinks about the stolen
vehicle that's a tough situation is
tough oof glad Insurance took care of
them all right you're the insurance Guru
I love insurance and Lynn's up next in
Cincinnati Lynn how are you
hi I'm good thank you what's going on
with you so Mike yes so my question is I
have about ten thousand dollars in a
life insurance policy my husband passed
away in 2020 and I have a parent plus
one oh thank you
um I have a parent plus loan that I owe
twenty twelve thousand dollars on
and so my question is
and I need a new vehicle but I've
decided to wait I put a little bit of
money like 1500 of that pen into
um you know just getting the car out to
the car and hoping to get me through two
or three years should I put the rest of
that money down on the Parent PLUS Loan
um I do have about a thousand dollars a
month set aside
um in my budget to put towards the
Parent PLUS Loan I just started this
whole budget scene with you guys so
um
yes welcome to the weirdos who budget
right
okay so you're doing the right things do
you have any other debt other than the
parent plus loan
mortgage which is you know 80 000. I had
to sell my home that we were living in
and I you know bought a new home that's
something I could afford myself okay so
yeah so 1500 is going on that house I
could
yeah that's great or we're going to
worry about that later on in what we
call baby step six and so right now baby
step two we're paying off the debt which
is the parent plus loan you said you're
gonna put 1500 into the repairs to get
the car functional for the next few
years
yes and then 8 500 towards the Parent
PLUS Loan which gets it down to 3 500.
yes and then putting a thousand a month
is that on top of the minimum payment
um that includes the minimum payment
okay so in the next four months you're
completely debt free
if you follow this plan and then you can
start building your emergency fund which
is three to six months of expenses do
you know what that would add up to
um yes I think it was about I added it
up once before and I think it was close
to like maybe twelve thousand perfect
and so that's our next goal and that
thousand you were spending on The Parent
PLUS Loan can now go go towards the
emergency fund and so I would love for
you to have that emergency fund within
six months
what's your income that would be great
um so I bring home about
a boxy every every two weeks okay
right and so with that you know 2600 a
month we're going to try to limit our
expenses as much as we can if you can do
any overtime or I'll work on the side to
increase that I want to get you that
Financial Foundation as soon as possible
so that you can begin investing are you
investing right now
um not really I mean I work for a school
system and so my retirement is set up
through them and I'm you know 52 years
old I I'm about ready to I can retire
now
but because of all that's happened in
the last two years I'm not retiring yet
oh I understand so well we want to get
you to a great financial spot so what
I'm going to do is gift you one year of
Financial Peace University as well as
every dollar our budgeting tool because
you've already got started on that and
we want to walk with you over the next
year as you build that foundation so
sorry for your loss and we're wishing
you the best on this journey thanks so
much for the call that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books my thanks
to my co-host Mr Ken Coleman and all the
folks in the booth we've got Austin and
James and Andrew and Zach the whole
gang's in there and you America thank
you for listening in we'll be back with
you before you know it until then spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously good show
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]